on a daily basis i'm on [ __ ] fire my  every minute is booked for 18 hours a  day and i'm fast fast let me take a step  back in a macro i'm very patient i'm  gonna always care about my reputation  and my name and how i'm viewed in  history so you have to be thoughtful and  patient building something meaningful a  relationship a business it takes 10 20  30 years too many of you are being  passive daily but judging yourselves by  the years i'm the reverse  i'm judging myself every minute here  right now every second viper but i'm  patient at the macro which makes me  happy daily daily daily speed yearly  early lyric patience there's something  here my friends that i'm trying to pass  to you  [Music]